hey youtubers is Charlie so hopefully
you guys have all had a chance to see
listen this weekend and since it's
something of a scary episode I thought
it'd be fun to talk about my top five
favorite scary Doctor Who episodes
horror is subjective but I feel like
there at least a few episodes everyone
can totally agree on being really scary
also if you thought classic who is scary
I mean imagine what it would've looked
like if Christopher Lee had been cast as
the doctor traumatized a generation
that's what it's all about
and real quick reminder this week's
giveaway is still running I'll ask the
winner my Q&A tomorrow if you're just
finding me for the first time all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so
here we go top five scary episodes of
Doctor Who starting with number five
family of blood shout out to Harry Lloyd
for being such an amazing creeper
there's something about Doctor Who
period episodes that make them feel
scarier maybe because everything looks
less familiar I feel like the new
monsters from listen in this week's
episode remind me of the scarecrow
monsters from family of blood and that
they are relatively featureless and they
don't speak I definitely think it's
scarier when monsters don't speak I will
say one of my favorite props from the
episode in addition to the doctors fob
watch of course is the red balloon that
sister mine has it's just so much
creepier when she carries around this
harmless looking red balloon the real
icing on the cake though is that after
it's all over it's the doctor that ends
up looking like the monster here are the
punishments that he handed out to the
family of blood so we have the sister
forever trapped in the mirror mother
would be forever falling into a star
father forever wrapped in chains and
brother forever a scarecrow in a field
it's all just because they wanted to
live forever that's all they wanted to
live forever and the doctor is like this
angry Djinn he grants their wishes but
in this really twisted evil way onto
number four brain of Morbius this is a
Fourth Doctor story involving a battle
with a renegade Time Lord Morbius I
think of it as being a twist on the
classic Frankenstein story where the
monster eventually turns on his master
so the classic episodes I think in
general just are a little bit creepier
because of the way they use music like
this weird synthesizer organ music that
just makes everything so much stranger
like a classic x-files episode with this
weird tonal music here's a fun fact from
behind the scenes this is one of the few
episodes and
of Doctor Who that features a gunshot
and blood pouring from a wound it's
incredibly violent if you'll remember in
this week's episode and listen there's a
reference to the doctor not carrying a
gun obviously he wasn't the one carrying
the gun in this old episode either the
dr. Frankenstein of the episode is
basically dr. salon who takes the hand
of his servant Kondo who already kind of
looks a little bit scary and sews it
onto Morbius the renegade Time Lord when
the servant realizes what's happened and
that salon replaced his taken hand with
a horrible looking hook he shoots Kondo
in the chest a bunch of times
thus the blood way more violent than
anything in modern whoo but on to number
three caves of Androzani this was the
fifth doctors final story the villain
Jack already had this kind of nightmare
inducing costume and makeup so not only
did he just looked scary in this really
post Star Wars burned face Darth Vader
way but he was utterly insane him
creeping on Perry will make you shiver
no matter how many times you watch it
because he's so crazy it's kind of hard
to tell if he wants to be with her or if
he wants to eat her for dinner it's like
this Buffalo Bill Silence of the Lambs
thing where he feels like a serial
killer so you can't really apply normal
logic to his actions to be fair that
Jake is more a villain of circumstance
than like a traditional black cat
wearing villain who's just straight up
evil you do feel a little bit of
sympathy for him but the whole story is
just one of the darkest regenerations
ever that would actually make a really
awesome list just ranking the doctors
regenerations from happiest to darkest
it just feels like classic who would
dominate a list like that because most
of the modern who regenerations have
been you know relatively positive but on
to number two empty child I feel like a
lot of Doctor Who tumblr reaction jib
sets use empty child gas mask picks just
for shock value the whole tone of this
episode works really well with the
intensity of the ninth doctor it just
keeps you on edge constantly which feels
like a ninth doctor kind of thing like
he's just walking around on edge so much
that he might jump out and strangle
someone one of the really fun twist
though was making it a zombie story but
taking it to this weird techy place by
using the nanovirus I do a ton of
Walking Dead videos during the year and
Robert Kirkman tells amazing zombie
stories but I feel like Doctor Who's
tekno zombies were a
twist in the genre ever since George
Romero created the genre essentially
with Dawn of the Dead almost every
single zombie story since then has been
a riff on his that's why I always give
extra points the stories like empty
child that can do a zombies story in a
unique way
one of my favorite scary moments from
the episode was when the doctor puts on
the gas mask at the end efforts all over
and repeats are you my mummy like he's
trying to be funny but he doesn't
understand that he's just horrifying
everyone it feels like a mean type of
joke they would give to compel his
doctor although his dark sense of humor
is a little less insane than the night
doctors I really do kind of feel like
the Ninth Doctor is the craziest of all
the new who doctors to be fair he was
fresh from the war so he was just
starting to deal with what he'd done
like he was still in shock so he had a
much harder time approximating normal
human social behavior but on to my
number one scary Doctor Who story of
course blink I know everyone picks this
as their scariest but that's because it
is the scariest story weeping angels
hands-down also my personal favorite
scary monster I mean how are you
supposed to avoid something that's tied
to your ability to not blink I mean you
have to blink it's a biological
imperative a lot of times I feel like
the doctor and his companions have only
escaped the Angels because they've been
in a group of people and the Angels
always grab the red shirts it's like
that situation where you know something
is chasing you you only have to be
faster than the person next to you you
don't have to be faster than the monster
I feel like a lot of the brilliance from
blink comes from the MacGuffin the VHS
tapes the doctor uses to communicate and
the execution of the angels themselves I
mean it could have turned into something
really ridiculous but the way that they
portrayed them on screen was just
brilliant they can't talk unless you
count angel Bob and they only move when
people in the episode characters aren't
looking at them and when we is the
audience can't see them think about it
this way you know usually when the
angels move on camera it's when the
camera is not on them or when the video
feed a character in the episode is
watching cuts out
then there's the teeth in the claws
whenever I watch Supernatural now and I
see the human form angels like Castille
walking around I still think of their
actual appearance as being something
more like weeping angels underneath it
just makes it so much more fun
I don't expect Moffat to bring the
Angels back in series ages because he
used them so much during the Matt Smith
and just in the Christmas special it's
possible they might include some visual
references to them in future episodes so
we'll keep our eyes peeled but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
what is your favorite scary episode of
Doctor Who it could be classic or modern
just flat-out most terror inducing
episode like I said the giveaway for
this week is still totally open til I
post my Q&A on Sunday tomorrow I'm sure
everyone still has a ton of questions
about that big twist at the end so if
you want to comment on it just use
spoiler tags just because people might
not have seen the episode yet but right
now click here to get the Q&A video I'll
have the annotation as soon as I post it
tomorrow and click here to get my
episode for review thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you